human beings are absolute pattern
detectors we spot patterns and we spot
structures so you can say look here is
this beautiful pattern and underneath
that pattern there is this wonderful
mathematical
idea part of the reason we find it
beautiful is because of its inherent
Symmetry and
proportion if you understand how
something is put together if you can see
that behind that beautiful form of
poetry art and music and literature the
beauty of architecture those shapes that
nature produces that's all mathematics
as
well my main research area has been
group Theory really it's the study of
symmetry that's how I like to think of
it a group is just a collection of
things which could be numbers it could
be functions it could be matrices all of
these things can form groups but the one
I like the most is groups of
symmetries numbers shapes symmetry all
of those things are there in the
universe the nature around
us and this one here this beautiful
flower it's got five petals and that
means it's got a fivefold symmetry you
can rotate it 1/ fif of the way around
the
circle you get lots of numbers like 5 8
13 that form part of the Fibonacci
sequence which is very very useful in
terms of plant growth because it relates
to something called the golden
ratio
if you look at a sunflower there are
loads of spiles with Fibonacci numbers
of seeds in them so the gold number is
there for sure and you see it as well in
some of the Spiral shapes of seashells
we have not invented the golden ratio
right we've discovered it and we see all
over
nature this is the absolute load Stone
of symmetry where I live these beautiful
designs created by William Morris with
Botanical themes plants and animals he
made Fabrics tapestries he made
wallpapers there are 17 different kinds
of wallpaper now this seems
counterintuitive because of course there
are as many kinds of wpaper as you could
design but what we're talking about
there is the ways that the patterns can
fit together these designs they're all
different but what they have in common
is that they all have symmetry to
them the famous artist MC designed lots
of repeating patterns and tessellations
he learned about the 17 wallpaper
patterns from his brother who was a
crystallographer and then of course Esha
produces all these wonderful designs um
that we all know and
love this collection of structures
actually has applications beyond the
design of wallpaper for instance Crystal
structures now if you think of the
layers of atoms that form inside a
crystal there are these 17 possibilities
so what's a symmetry something you can
do to that design that leaves it looking
the same there are lots of vertical
mirror lines you could draw reflect this
design it's going to look the same
either way you could also shift it along
in steps so you could translate it
that's the mathematical word so it's
very very cool the way the symmetries
can combine like this and that's one of
the properties that they must satisfy to
form this algebraic object called a
group so in this case we've got a
collection of all the symmetries of this
beautiful design and anytime you combine
any of them the outcome is still another
symmetry just
check two three four
five there's not one connection between
mathematics and music there are many
it's got so much mathematics in The
rhythms the patterns even the counting
the way that frequencies match up to
produce sounds that we find pleasing
together the mathematician liit said
that music is what happens when we do
mathematics
unconsciously you can't listen to a
piece of bar without knowing that it's
mathematical the beautiful patterns and
symmetries in that music if you're
listening to a Fugue or playing a Fugue
on the piano um you'll get a theme that
comes in and then it comes back but it's
upside down inverted or it might be
retrograde backwards or it might be
translated up or down so these are just
the same kinds of symmetries that we saw
in the in the wallpaper right people
somehow they get put off the idea of
mathematics they think mathematics is
about numbers and numbers are not
creative they're rigid whereas art is
more free and creative actually of
course that is that is not right the
most creative subject for me is
mathematics it's just that we're
creating with with ideas with patterns
so yes music is mathematics just as art
is mathematics and so is literature
everything is
mathematics
[Music]